das ist doch herzukommen gehört ich bin
heute wieder völlig am start heute
zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen mehr in
quarantäne gammel look man sieht hier so
ein bisschen ich bin ein bisschen will
müssen
solltest du dein gesicht einige rote
druckstellen haben dann liegt es daran
dass ich gerade mit einem viel zu
kleinen motorrad von einem kumpel mein
moped fahrer war es wieder ausgepackt
habe soviel vorneweg und damit er
bescheid bis heute wir machen heute
weiter mit einem neuen hilfen video
leute und ich kann euch sagen was euch
vielleicht beruhigen wird die letzten
videos waren ja ab und zu mal dass ich
schon ein bisschen in eine se iksu elle
richtung gedriftet sind wohl nicht wieso
regierung soll das auf youtube sein
heute ist es einfach nur guter alter
häfen könig einfach einfach nur ein
kräftespiel ist ganz simpel man wird
dümmer gehirnzellen sterben dieser
sollte das video amazing horse mein
geheimes doppelleben leute und wir reden
lernzentrum let's go
[Musik]
oh mein gott leute genau so was brauche
ich mal wieder leute kennt ist ja das
gefühl auch als kann genau so was habe
ich mal wieder gebraucht ich kann nicht
die ganze zeit irgendwelche videos
reinziehen volksschule jungs die ve brgm
in die schule bringen ich brauche
einfach mal so was hier das ist einfach
geil leute das ist wirklich all das ist
einfach erfrischend das ist für mich
wirklich gerade erfrischend einfach so
richtig richtig dumm für hilfen videos
zu schauen so richtig geil stumpf es ist
einfach nur dumm
es ist ein produkt hängen geblieben ohne
irgendwas was da noch hinten dran ist
was vielleicht ernst nein nein es ist
einfach dumm und das ist einfach nur ich
bin in einer neuen theatergruppe genau
wenn du mich an die dialoge sind haben
sie beide torhüter ich bin in einer
neuen theatergruppe ich sehe genau denn
du mich annimmt so direkt aufeinander
ohne irgendwie denkpause oder so
dazwischen so als hätten sie das schon
20 mal aufgenommen und wüssten wirklich
auf die millisekunde genau wann der
anderen mit seinem text aufhört ja geil
einfach schlecht
sie wäre ein fehler ein
hier werden gleich mal langsam ein
bisschen ungehalten wenn menschen in
einem pferde kostüm durch den garten
rennen wollen und wir wollen als ob sie
in gott verdammt geil wehren und vier
weine hätten und den ganzen möhren
fressen würden dann lass dir machen weil
weil ich glaube dass diese personen auf
der rechten seite kommt mir ein bisschen
bekannt vor ich glaube die hat eine
längere hilfen die vergangenheit schauen
wir kurz nach genau hier ja es gab mal
eine hilfe folge die heißt ein bisschen
bi schadet nie ja ich würde würde auch
passen wenig für seine pferde lieben es
ist einfach müll einfach rest mehr leute
das ist wie das fühlt sich gerade
wirklich so anders
nachdem jetzt videos die echt bisschen
krasser waren muss ich sagen also auch
ein bisschen anstrengend so beim
anschauen das hört sich wirklich wie an
es würde man so dieses eine mal im monat
zu mcdonald's gehen sich denken so jetzt
gebe ich mir bewusst richtigen schmutz
und das ist auch ganz schlecht über
leute ganz schlecht ist immer so
menschen um gehört zu bitten und ihnen
zu sagen dass man alles erklären kann
wenn man währenddessen einfach ein
pferde kostüm trägt
ok also prinzipiell jetzt mal derart
stadt für euch wenn ihr in einer
situation ernsthaftigkeit ausstrahlen
wollten sagen wollte jetzt bin ich ernst
hör mir zu seid nicht als tier
verkleidet ja ich bete ich bete dafür
dass sie jetzt mit diesem pferde kostüm
im kaffee trinken geht bitte bitte tut
mir den gefallen hat mir auch sonst
klappt schon wieder auch mal alles von
das macht doch mal ja
und lass uns doch mal nicht darüber
reden dass die die blonde einfach ihr so
die freundschaft kündigt weil sie sie in
einem tier kostüm angetroffen hat das
ist vielleicht auch ist übertrieben es
in ihrem leben schief gelaufen wie ist
hier an diesem punkt angekommen welche
welche geistige störung liegt davor dass
sie sich entschieden hatte
ich finde es einfach geil zu wehren
das gibt es ja wirklich eine hobby horse
ist das glaube ich meine leute die sich
als als pferde in ihrer freizeit
verkleiden und ich mein okay wenn du
willst ich meine jetzt ist es ist eine
hilfe erfolgen sie macht sich darüber
lustig aber wenn es ein ding ist jetzt
verteilen dann meine macht halt so aber
ich frage mich halt was ist da was ist
daran so geil wie kommt man an den punkt
dass man sich denkt bruder
es wäre so geilen fährt zu sein wie
kommt man an diesem punkt also warum
nicht also muss man jetzt auch nicht
gehen also wieder es ist ja tatsächlich
ein echtes hobby so hobby haus gibt es
ja das ist ja genau wie das gibt es ja
aber man muss jetzt nicht so weit gehen
dass man leute sagen lässt dass ihr
berufswunsch in der kindheit fährt war
fährt ist kein beruf okay es tut einfach
gut kannte kreta schnuppern ich bin weg
von dem alltäglichen stress und mein
kopf ist so frei wenn ich einmal am tag
führen kann ich mache es tagtäglich
wahrscheinlich ist das besser als ich
die bürde weg zu saufen oder sonst
irgendwas übrigen drogen sicherheit zu
haben weil wahrscheinlich ist es noch
besser dass man sich denkt in meinem
pferd wenn es zum stressabbau gutes
oppliger macht erding aber ich würde ich
würde an der stelle sagen heute lebe ich
mal ganz verlassen fenster
möglicherweise gibt es dann noch paar
tiefer liegende probleme und dieses
pferd sein ist nur ein ventil dafür aber
wer bin ich ja vor den kann man nicht
kann man nicht als mensch an gräsern
schnuppern nimmt das geht nicht wir
haben ja keine nasen hast du was auch
krank ist in zwei hilfen erfolgen wir zu
machen
das ist auch krank und die brille also
ja weißt nicht was habe ich denn daran
jetzt verstehen ich kann beim fahren so
abschalten
aber ich kann hier noch was zeigen also
was das ist geil das ist geil das ist
geil
sie kann beim viren abschenken leute
einfach mal einfach mal was für sich tun
müsst ihr einfach mal der aus dem
alltäglichen stress entkommen dem an der
schule im beruf im studium hat wo auch
immer einfach malen viren
ich glaube das ist ein geschäftsmodell
oder für sie komplett verballerte hängen
gebliebene menschen mache ich halt immer
so ein wochenende wahrscheinlich zahlen
dafür mit mir irgendwie ein
konferenzzentrum irgendwann deutschland
laut 200 leute ein mit so eine koppel
sondern können die herumlaufen und
können wir geben hier 50 euro 2 50 eur
10.000 euro nämlich dann wenn das
wochenende
ich habe noch ein paar sachen
auch mal kurze frage wohnt sie in einem
gartenhaus
so müssen also wenn ich mir das so
anschaue dass sie sehr nach gartenhaus
aus über also wenn ich weiß nicht wie
viel nähe zu meiner lebenssituation
nicht von jemandem erwarten kann der
gerne ein pferd ist und der es als
stressreduktion empfindet zu wir ja okay
vielleicht nicht so viel aber die klapse
im ernst ich sollte also ich wie gesagt
ich glaube es gibt schon einige leute
die halt auch dieses hobby haben aber
ganz ehrlich wir sind 84 millionen
menschen in deutschland oder hast du so
um den dreh so natürlich es gibt für
jedes hobby ein paar dutzend für jedes
noch so krank wie gibt es ein paar
dutzend leute die das machen
dafür sind wir einfach zu viel meine
meinung dazu ist wie so ein großteil
dieser leute in so richtig seltsamen
hobbys reinkommt ist weil sie mit ihrem
leben mit ihrem alltag aus irgend einem
grund nicht klarkommen weil es irgendwie
zu viel isst sie müssen das irgendwie
verarbeiten das ja auch kein problem
erst mal und dann kommen die auf irgend
eine zufällige art und weise auf die
idee dass sie jetzt ein pferd sein
müssen und dieses pferd seien es so
fluss flucht aus der realität und
deswegen kommt in dieses hobby rein so
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ob da so
viele geistig gesunde mensch drin sind
wir tragen nach ihrer geheimen pferde
leidenschaft er ist viel zu starr kennen
[Musik]
das wird richtig gut
ja ja das tut richtig gut
also was ich kann was ist das der weg
wie findet man wie findet man menschen
für solche rollen wie geht das
wie findet man einen menschen der bei
sowas mitspielt das kann das macht doch
kein vernünftiger mensch mit
jetzt werden diese abend ihre
traumatisiert also die nehmen das ganz
gut an
achtet mal drauf die dga die spieler
voll möchten ist keine von uns dass sie
dass dieses lebewesen hände hat das ist
ja wahrscheinlich aufgefallen und damit
entlaste ich sehr gerne verschenkt die
drüben für euch vorgeschlagen ist wieder
auf jung könnte meinte haben ich bin in
der stadt heraus macht's gut
sucht euch andere wegen stress abzubauen
als ein pferd zu seinen servieren und
bleibt stabil